[musique]
Pierre Azon, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
D'abord, merci de votre accueil.
Euh j'ai fait des relations
internationales, du droit international,
des études stratégiques et puis surtout
après, j'ai fait 20 ans de journalisme
et puis par la suite, j'ai travaillé
dans la médiation des conflits armés.
Vous êtes Suisse ?
Je suis Suisse, oui. [grognement]
On embrasse Lausanne, on les
et Genève aussi. et Genève, on les
embrasse fort. D'ailleurs,
on vous a décidé de vous faire venir euh
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez créé un
un bon bouquin sur "Faut-il négocier
avec le diable ?" Et à quoi
s'expose-t-on ? Et on va dire que le
sujet est d'actualité. [rires]
Comment ? Quel regard vous portez sur
les processus de paix ? Est-ce que c'est
sain, pas sain ? Est-ce que ça nous
emmène pas vers un simplement une petite
couverture de résolution et le conflit
couvre toujours et ne demande qu'à se
réveiller à la moindre escarmouche ?
Comment ça se passe en ce moment ? La la
résolution, la médiation et faut-il
encore parler au diable ?
D'ailleurs, c'est qui le diable ? On est
toujours le diable de quelqu'un.
C'est bien vrai. C'est bien vrai.
Euh je crois que il faut remonter un
tout petit peu à l'histoire et c'est
vrai que si on pense à Cicéron, il
disait que le les pirates sont les
ennemis du genre humain, c'est-à-dire
qu'à chaque période, il y a eu des
diables. Euh si on prend pense au
Moyen-Âge, il y avait les sorcières, il
y avait les hérétiques qu'on brûlait
pour purifier soi-disant.
Euh sur Ronald Rigan, l'Empire du mal,
c'était l'Union soviétique.
Plus récemment après
Sabrinita, après le génocide de Rwanda,
c'était les criminels de guerre ou ceux
qu'on désigné comme tel. Par la suite,
après les attentats contre les tours
jumelles du 11 septembre, c'est devenu
les terroristes. Aujourd'hui, peut-être
c'est un mélange et on voit et peut-être
on pourra en parler plus longuement euh
comment le vocabulaire est évolué et
comment peut-être pour Poutine est
devenu pour le monde occidental la
figure du diable. Et je trouve ça
extraordinairement intéressant que d'un
côté il y a le la notion de crime de
guerre, de crime contre l'humanité, même
de génocide qui est utilisé par les deux
camps, y compris et surtout par Poutine
au début. Et de l'autre côté, la semaine
dernière encore, les sénateurs
américains, aussi bien démocrates que
républicains, demandaient à ce que la
Russie soit classée comme un état
sponsor du terrorisme. Ce que le
président Biden a refusé. Et donc on
voit bien comment se crée la figure du
diable, comment on diabolise. Ceci dit,
ce qui est vrai, c'est qu'il y a des
crimes horribles qui sont effectivement
commis et que Dieu merci, il faut
essayer de faire en sorte qu' d'une part
qu'il en ait moins, que la justice d'une
certaine manière évidemment doit passer
mais que pour qu'elle puisse passer
aussi, il faut laisser une place à la
médiation et au dialogue.
Comment on fait pour avoir un dialogue ?
Comment on fait pour réconcilier des
parties qui se détestent jusqu'au fond
au plus profond de leur âme ? Il faut
les mettre autour d'une table, éteindre
la lumière et et choisir qu'il se
battent dans une seule pièce pour éviter
que les populations civiles en prennent
plein la tête. Il faut une puissance
extérieure, respecter des deux camps.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut ?
Tous les cas sont absolument
spécifiques. Et donc il y a évidemment
il y a jamais de formule. Jamais jamais
jamais.
D'abord ce qu'on constate et on peut
prendre des exemples très concrets,
pensons, tout le monde parle de Poutine
aujourd'hui et la grande discussion
c'est faut-il ou non discuter avec la
Russie. Moi, ce que je regarde de
manière très très simple, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières semaines ? Il
y a eu un accord sur les échanges,
plusieurs accords sur les échanges de
prisonniers, y compris par
l'intermédiaire parfois du CICR et des
Nations- Unies. Ça veut dire pour les
gens qui ne savent pas
le comité international de la
Croix-Rouge. Donc ce qui veut dire c'est
que oui, il a fallu discuter avec les
deux parties. Deuxièmement, il y a eu
des des experts de l'AUA de l'agence de
l'énergie éthomique qui se sont rendus à
la centrale de Zaporja pour contrôler
pour ce qui s'est passé et pour essayer
en quelque sorte de limiter les dangers
et l'escalades. Là encore, il a fallu
négocier et discuter. Troisièmement, ces
dernières semaines, il y a eu l'accord
qui s'est produit avec la médiation
turque et des Nations- Unies sur les
exportations de céréales et de
fertilisants pour l'Ukraine et la
Russie. Donc là encore, il a fallu
négocier ce que je crois que dans très
souvent dans la tête de beaucoup de
gens, il y a l'idée que il faudrait que
qu'il y ait une sorte euh
d'une table où tout le monde se mettrait
autour pour un sorte de règlement final.
Mais avant d'en arriver là, il y a des
dizaines et dizaines d'heures
d'approches de discussions et souvent
sur des accords tout à fait ponctuel.
Là, j'en ai cité trois, mais on peut
prendre n'importe quel autre conflit. Et
euh effectivement c'est que ces accords
ponctuels sont importants parce que
d'une part ils limitent l'escalade, ils
apprennent à chaque partie à à mesurer
les lignes rouges, hein, à établir une
sorte de grammaire et et donc tout ça
participe d'une certaine manière à
instaurer un dialogue minimal. Alors
évidemment, si on parle maintenant de
l'Ukraine et la Russie, on est très loin
du règlement. Tout les trois exemples
que je vous ai cés sont des exemples
périphériques. On touche pas le cœur du
du conflit. Euh il faut pour cela que
les conditions cadres soient réunies,
que l'environnement soit réussi soit
réuni.
Les sanctions, est-ce que ça marche ?
Est-ce que ça fonctionne pour la
résolution des conflits ?
Moi, je vais vous donner un exemple tout
à fait personnel.
Il y a quelques années, j'ai reçu le
représentant de de l'administration
américaine. Lequel ?
Euh c'était sous c'était le c'était
entre Obama et Trump. Et
l'administration de Trump venait d'être
en place et cette personne était en en
place mais elle avait été nommée par
Obama. et euh et il m'explique euh que
voilà les États-Unis et l'Union
européenne ont pris des sanctions et que
forcément le gouvernement dont il parle
et je peux pas citer le nom, n'existera
plus d'ici 6 mois.
Moi je je le regarde, je suis un peu
dubitatif euh et je dis bon soit euh
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement est toujours
en place mais la personne qui m'a dit ça
depuis longtemps rejoint le domaine
privé et n'est plus du tout dans la
fonction publique. Donc je suis très
sceptique sur de manière générale sur
les sanctions euh parce que souvent
elles ont un effet contre-productif.
Elle il y a tout le maré, toute la
partie de l'opinion publique euh qui est
qui hésite, qui est pas forcément en
faveur de la guerre, mais tout à coup on
on la pousse souvent dans les bras euh
des plus des plus extrêmes parce qu'ils
sont directement touchés. Alors que les
gens qui sont tout au haut de la
pyramide, souvent ils mettent en place
des réseaux et mettent en place des
monopoles qui leur permettent de
s'enrichir encore davantage. Donc
souvent c'est contre productif,
il faut bien faire quelque chose.
Mais en même temps, voilà, c'est
exactement le point que j'allais dire.
Maintenant, si on prend le cas
particulier spécifique de l'Ukraine, il
suffit il y a une agression donc
forcément il faut faire quelque chose.
Et donc les sanctions effectivement,
elles ont leur raison d'être. Encore
faut-il que ça soit les sanctions les
plus intelligentes possibles.
Est-ce que les forces d'interposition ça
fonctionne ?
Est-ce que c'est pas un décorum d'un
autre siècle quand il y a deux
superpuissances ou une grosse
superpuissance qui débarque comme ça ?
et qui menace en disant toute puissance
qui se mettra sur notre chemin se sera
considéré comme celligérant ou du moins
coagresseur ou ou co cole
de l'OTAN, comment ça s'appelle ?
Excusez-moi.
Oui. la solidarité atlantique qui fait
que l'intervention immédiate
et donc quand on a la Russie qui menace
les autres puissances en disant si vous
mettez sur notre route, vous serez
considéré comme ennemi. Est-ce que ça
pouvait fonctionner une force
d'interposition des casques bleus
européens ?
Pour qu'il y ait une pour qu'il y ait
des casques bleus, il faut que les deux
parties soient d'accord. Donc à partir
de là euh c'est pas possible. Donc euh
donc euh donc effectivement euh ce pour
espérer pour esquisser un un processus
de paix. Euh donc la première chose
c'est que il y a un certain nombre de
choses. Je crois que il faut sortir de
l'idée que c'est du tout ou rien. La
guerre c'est quelque chose profondément
horrible, profondément dramatique. Et
donc tout ce qui peut tout ce qui peut
être utilisé pour limiter la souffrance
des populations doit être fait. Euh je
vous donne euh des exemples tout à fait
concrets. Euh euh un certain nombre
parlons de groupes armés disons
particulièrement euh je pense à
l'organisation de l'État islamique.
C'est tout sauf de des enfants de cœur.
On est bien d'accord. C'est euh
alors la question, je trouvais
intéressant que effectivement un certain
nombre d'organisations humanitaire
doivent parler avec ces avec ces groupes
pour atteindre finalement pour pouvoir
donner pour avoir accès à des
populations et pour pouvoir leur
distribuer de l'aide humanitaire. Donc
si vous voulez, la question du dialogue
me paraît essentielle. La question
fondamentale, c'est rester sur une ligne
de crête, pas déborder la ligne de
crête. Parce que d'un côté euh vous
devez parler avec des bad guys. Et
encore, j'étais frappé par ce qu'a dit
le pape il y a quelques jours à peine.
Il a dit il faut parler avec les agress,
il veut vous parler y compris avec les
agresseurs même quand ça pue. Et ça pue
et souvent ça pue. Mais ceci dit, la
question c'est effectivement il faut
parler mais il faut avoir un objectif
clair et rester sur cette ligne de crète
en disant on va faire du bien et on va
pas devenir on va pas tomber du côté de
la compromission ou de la complicité. Or
parfois le la marge est très fine et
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai écrit ce
livre parce que à la fois
com s'appelle comment il s'appelle le
livre
Négocier avec le diable. Je vais je vais
vous le montrer brièvement mais c'est
pas l'enjeu de la discussion. Allez, on
peut le poser mais on va le remontrer
après
si vous voulez. Euh
euh mais du coup j'ai perdu le fil
quand ça pue. Il faut quand même
négocier. Il faut quand même continuer à
maintenir
il faut maintenir il faut maintenir les
canaux de discussion ouverts
sans se compromettre.
Sans se compromettre. Et c'est ça c'est
vraiment ça la limite très très fine. Et
par exemple dans le livre, je donne
plusieurs exemples qui m'ont qui m'ont
marqué très très profondément.
Je vais peut-être vous parler d'une
histoire qui peut-être a été un peu le
déclencheur de ce livre et qui remonte à
qui remonte à près de 30 ans en réalité.
Voilà, je suis journaliste à ce
moment-là, je travaille pas du tout dans
la médiation des conflits armés. Je suis
intégré à une équipe d'humanitaire
et
cette équipe d'humanitaire reçoit un
mandat très particulier. Alors grande
surprise, c'est que on doit aller dans
un camp particulièrement horrible où il
y a 2000 hommes qui sont maltraités. Un
certain nombre d'entre eux ont été tués.
Quel pays ? en Bosn Herzegovin
et euh et une négociation qui s'est
passée à très haut niveau fait que cette
équipe d'humanitaire doit choisir de
libérer un/3 des 2000 hommes. Ces 2000
hommes sont dans une sorte d'ancien
entrepôt de la GNA, donc l'armée
et vivent dans des conditions infectes.
Ils ont tous perdu entre 20 30 kg ou
plus.
Et donc la question se pose pour nous
comment comment choisir et donc vous
connaissez le le film le livre le choix
de Sophie et donc on se trouvait presque
dans cette situation absolument horrible
de en tout cas tragique de devoir
choisir entre des gens de ceux qui
seraient libérés et ceux qui resteraient
dans cette prison là. Et donc, il y
avait un médecin parmi nous qui a dit
"Ben, je veux pas être un docker molet.
Euh et donc il faut agir de la manière
la plus rationnelle possible." Et la
manière la plus rationnelle possible, ça
a été de faire un ce qu'il appelait un
body mass index. C'est-à-dire qu'on est
allé avec des balances, des mètres. On a
mis une petite table au milieu du camp
et par équipe de trois, on se on se
relayait.
C'est horrible. et on a on a mesuré
pendant des jours et pesé pendant des
jours tous ces 2000 prisonniers pour
établir une liste en disant voilà le
ratio des plus faibles, c'est cela. Donc
on se disait on est du bon côté, on a
fait la chose la plus juste possible.
Et c'est à ce moment-là, mais c'est à ce
moment-là précisément que j'ai compris
ce que c'est qu'une guerre civile. Parce
que il y avait un type euh
qui était en charge des échanges de
prisonniers et lui il
avait identifié les prisonniers qui
avaient de la valeur et ceux qui avaient
pas de la valeur.
En quel terme la valeur ? la valeur
monétaire, c'est-à-dire que qui a de la
famille à l'étranger, en Allemagne, en
Suisse, en Autriche et qui peut envoyer
de l'argent pour le libérer ou pour
faire un échange avec l'autre côté ou un
grade assez haut et donc il avait sa
propre liste de ceux dont il voulait se
débarrasser parce qu'il trouvait qu'ils
avaient pas de valeur en fait. Et donc
on était on était liste contre liste et
le front était à une dizaine de
kilomètres, on entendait que que ça
tirait en fait.
Donc et c'est là où j'ai vraiment senti
euh quelque chose Oui. Le sentiment de
jusqu'où faut-il aller et cette équipe
d'humanitaire c'est c'est presque scindé
en deux en fait. Il y avait une partie
qui disait "On peut pas négocier sur la
peau des gens. Il est prêt à libérer 700
personnes sur les 2000. On les prend, on
les sauve."
Et celui qui était qui avait qui faisait
qui était en charge du droit disait
"Non, il faut tenir sur le principe
parce que si on lâche ici et bien on
lâchera toujours donc il faut tenir
bon." Donc on a eu un conflit interne à
cette organisation humanitaire
en plein milieu du camp sur cette
questionlà.
Et c'est là où j'ai véritablement
compris à quel point c'est difficile
de d'être d'être de tenir sur la ligne
de crête. Qu'est-ce que c'est la bonne
décision ? Jusqu'où vous pouvez aller ?
Donc c'est et donc la question c'est à
ce moment-là que la question de la
complicité m'a aussi fait beaucoup
réfléchir. Est-ce que par exemple en
Bosnir Tegovin ou plus tard en Syrie,
est-ce que face à des dictateurs, face à
des hommes qui veulent déplacer des
populations
qui torturent, qui violent,
oui, mais je reviens sur la question qui
torture et qui viole et tout ça, mais je
reviens sur cette question de la du
déplacement forcé des populations, ce
qu'on appelle le nettoyage ethnique.
Est-ce que d'un côté un crime de guerre
? C'est évident que c'est un crime de
guerre.
La question pour une partie tierce qui
est humanitaire ou qui fait de la
médiation, c'est est-ce que faut-il ou
non d'une certaine manière les aider à à
humaniser ce processus qui est un
processus criminel pour que il y a moins
de gens qui souffrent durant ce
processus ou pas ? Donc vous voyez à
quel point c'est compliqué et donc je
prétends pas venir avec des
solutions toutes faites, il y en a pas.
Mais ce qui me semblait important, c'est
c'est d'inciter, c'est de poser les
problèmes, c'est d'inciter à la
réflexion, c'est de susciter une
discussion interne, une conversation
interne au sein même des parfois des
organisations pour savoir comment on
gère ces questionslà parce que c'est il
y a beaucoup de gris et donc on est dans
le brouillard de la guerre, parfois dans
le brouillard de la paix aussi ou de la
recherche de la paix et donc il faut
cheminer dans ce processus là.
les les gens aux manettes de ces
processus de paix,
ils en ressortent comment
psychologiquement
quand il voi quand ils sentent l'odeur
de la mort dans des camps quand il voi
corps décharnés torturés mutilés quand
ça leur prend la gorge psychologiquement
parlant sont dans quel état ?
Écoutez, c'est une réponse. Je sais pas,
j'ai jamais vu d'études là-dessus. Je
euh je pense que c'est des réponses
individuelles. Je sais que plusieurs
organisations humanitaires ou de
médiation ont mis en place des des
comment dire des des psychologues
qui travaillent avec sur la question du
traumatisme secondaire en fait. Mais
c'est vrai que effectivement quand vous
voyez un certain nombre de choses, c'est
effectivement
compliqué.
Qu'est-ce qui gêne les processus de paix
? C'est les bélicises des plateaux télé.
C'est le manque de d'appropriation du
sujet des populations civiles. C'est les
gens qui tirent un peu les ficelles à
gauche comme à droite. Qu'est-ce qui
gêne le travail des humanitaires en
dehors des béérants même ?
En dehors des belligérants,
écoutez, je sais pas. Je pense que enfin
l'image que j'ai en tête c'est d'avoir
une porte avec une dizaine de serrures
et cette dizaine de il faut pour qu'une
médiation marche, il faut que les 10
serrures ouvrent en même temps en fait.
C'est pour ça que c'est si compliqué. Il
faut que ça soit le bon timing, les bons
interlocuteurs, que le sang a
suffisamment coulé et que les gens en
ont marrent et que même à haut niveau
qui a une pression de la société des
gens qui souffrent, qui s'exercent, qui
a une qui a un compromis qui soit qui
soit mauvais pour les deux parties d'une
certaine manière.
Après évidemment, il y a les
intervenants extérieurs et c'est vrai
que on peut prendre un certain nombre de
situations tout à fait concrète et que
des guerres civiles deviennent des
guerres civiles internationalisées.
Si on parlait de la Syrie par exemple,
en Syrie par exemple, à un certain
moment, il y avait d'un côté le
gouvernement avec les milices qu'il
avait généré ou qu'il soutenait ou qu'il
payait et de l'autre côté, il y avait
plus d'une centaine de groupes armés.
plus d'une centaine de groupes armés
plus euh plus les Russes, plus les
Américains, plus euh les Turcs, plus XX
XX. Et d'ailleurs, on a vu quelque chose
qu'on avait jamais jamais vu dans un
conflit. Vous aviez la guerre en en
Syrie et en même temps pour éviter des
confrontations entre les puissances
extérieur, vous avez les Russes qui ont
signé simultanément un accord de non
confrontation avec les Américains, un
deuxè avec les Turcs et un troisème avec
les Israéliens. Alors, vous pouvez très
vous pouvez le constater. Lorsque les
Israéliens frappent le Esbola en Syrie,
et bien le les Turcs, les Turcs,
qu'est-ce que je dis ? Les Russes
n'interviennent pas, ils laissent faire.
Donc vous voyez aujourd'hui comment on
n'est plus du tout dans les conflits
presque d'entemp où il y avait un nombre
limité d'acteurs. Là on est souvent dans
des processus extraordinairement problè
problématique où le ticket d'entrée
d'abord et devient de moins en moins
cher pour des groupes armés pour se
constituer avec les réseaux sociaux une
caisse de propagande absolument immense
et puis des intervenants extérieurs de
plus en plus nombreux sans parler du
rôle de la diaspora et d'autres choses
aussi. Donc vous voyez à quel point ça
devient compliqué. On le voit en Syrie
mais on le voit au Mali aujourd'hui. On
le voit partout en fait.
Vous avez voyagé un petit peu je pense
non ?
J'ai voyagé un petit peu. Ouis.
[raclement de gorge]
Les conflits que vous avez pu voir de
très près, le Libéria, Morovia,
l'Afghanistan, la Syrie ?
Écoutez, j'ai passé le plus de temps en
Bosnie, au Rwanda, en Centraf-afrique,
dans le Sahel.
euh en Afghanistan, au Soudan,
j'en oublie.
Quel regard vous portez sur les débuts
de conflit ? comment ça se passe et
comment la justice peut passer derrière
quand on a violé le droit international,
quand on est parti sous de faux
prétextes, quand on a dit on partait là
mais en fait non mais on avait d'autres
intérêts ailleurs. Comment le droit
international est respecté par les
grandes puissances,
les grandes et les petites ?
Euh
il y a deux questions là totalement
différentes. Un c'est le début et
l'autre c'est presque la justice et
c'est plutôt vers la fin. Euh le début
et au milieu, il va falloir en parler
après. [rires]
D'accord. Alors, le début, c'est le
début, ben d'abord c'est la
déshumanisation, c'est la guerre
culturelle, c'est-à-dire c'est les
médias, c'est les réseaux sociaux, c'est
tout ce qui participe à travailler les
opinions publiques à travers les
sociétés, travailler sur le sentiment
d'être victime, le sentiment
d'humiliation. Et dans chaque peuple, le
sentiment d'humiliation existe
finalement. Et donc plus on travaille
ça, plus on génère des sentiments, plus
on génère des émotions, plus on fait
monter une sorte de passion et de
passion froide et ou de passion chaude
et haineuse en fait. Et c'est et c'est
ça qui devient très très compliqué après
à
à démêler parce qu'une fois qu'elle est
montée, une fois que le sang commence à
couler et bien effectivement
on arrive à à des situations de plus en
plus complexes et de plus en plus
tragiques.
Après la question du droit,
en fait il y a une révolution juridique
dans les années 90, une révolution
juridique absolument étonnante. Tout à
coup, en 93,
il y a eu l'idée d'avoir en même temps
que la guerre la justice internationale.
C'est une idée qui est neuve et
assez
surprenante
parce que traditionnellement, il y a le
temps de la guerre, il y a le temps de
la paix et puis parfois il y a la
justice un petit peu.
Et donc moi, j'étais fasciné par ça
quand quand dans les années 90. Donc je
voulais comprendre. Et donc j'ai après
la Bosnie, après le Rwanda quand j'ai vu
tous ces procé ces commissions vérité
qui se mettaient en place, ces procés
tribunaux pénaux internationaux qui se
mettaient en place, j'étais vraiment
fasciné. Et donc surtout après couverse
tous ces conflits, je me suis dit je
vais je vais essayer de mieux
comprendre. Et donc j'étais trouvé
l'homme un ministre français
qui s'appelait
Roland Duma. [raclement de gorge]
Feu Roland Duma.
Feu Roland Duma qui était le porteur de
la résolution 808 et 827 du Conseil de
sécurité aux Nations-Unies. Ces deux
résolutions
ont quelque part changé l'histoire du
droit international puisque elles ont
établi le tribunal pénal international
pour l'exégoslavie.
Donc
je sais, je me trouve en je dire en 98
pardon en 98.
On a le droit de ça ici.
On a le droit. Vous parlez suisse aussi.
Euh donc euh
je vais trouver Roland Dumain. Je dis
quand même vous avez fait un truc quand
même totalement étonnant. 1993
résolution 808 827 création du TPY.
1994,
génocide Rwanda résolution 955 qui
établit le tribunal pénal international
pour le Rwanda.
Euh 1998,
statut de Rome, processus la création de
la Cour pénale internationale.
Donc finalement, vous êtes à l'origine
d'une révolution juridique et je le dis
avec énormément de naïveté.
et il me regarde
et il me regarde en se avec un petit
sourire.
Elle me dit "Mais non, pas du tout, pas
du tout. Moi, j'avais un autre problème.
Moi, j'avais peur la France, j'avais
très peur que Mitteran et moi on soit un
jour accusé d'être complice des crimes
commis par les Bosnuerbes.
Alors, quand Roland Duma est venu vers
vers moi avec cette idée un peu
idéaliste de tribunal pénal
international, je me suis dit
formidable. D'un côté, on met une épée
de Damecles sur les béigérants, on leur
fait peur et comme ça ils vont ils vont
peut-être se calmer, commettre moins de
crime, mais surtout on aura un bouclier
et comme ça on va jamais nous reprocher
quoi que ce soit puisque c'est
nous-mêmes qui avons porté la résolution
qui créait le tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex-égoslavie. Moi,
je suis complètement sié et donc je lui
demande de répéter et il répète et et
donc j'ai bien entendu quoi. Et donc
quelque part je suis là et et du coup je
je rebondis, je dis "Ah c'est pour ça
que la France n'a jamais collaboré avant
Chirak avec le TPY ?" Il me dit "Oui,
évidemment. Euh et donc je suis effaré
par le cynisme évidemment
et en même temps j'ai trouvé que c'était
il y a tellement de leçons à tirer de
ça. D'un côté, il y a un homme qui
cherche un objectif essentiel, il veut
que ça soit serve aussi pour comme une
épée de Damoclè bien même s'il en donne
pas les moyens.
Euh mais en même temps Roland Duumain un
jour quitte les affaires, mais le
tribunal pénal international va
continuer à exister. Donc même si un
tribunal est créé de manière cynique, de
manière politisée, peut-être il a une
véritable valeur ensuite. Et c'est ça
qui est très surprenant et et donc
presque réconfortant moralement.
Après euh
après, on voit que durant la guerre de
de Bosnir Tegovin, le tribunal n'a pas
véritablement fonctionné.
Il a pratiquement rien fait.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Le tribunal est
créé officiellement en 1993.
Sabrinita c'est quand ?
Juste avant non
1995 2 ans plus tard. Excusez-moi. Oui.
2 ans plus tard. C'est-à-dire que le
tribunal qui était censé avoir un effet
préventif il n'en a eu zéro. En tout cas
pour la Bosnekovine.
Donc
tout ça nous
rappelz c'est c'est un massacre. 8000,
c'est un massacre organisé de manière
systématique de 8000 hommes de ou dans
de d'adolescents de plus de 16 ans dans
une enclave qui est une enclave des
Nations- Unies protégé par les Nations-
Unies où les Nations- Unies ont garanti
la vie de ceux qui vivent à l'intérieur
mais les Nations- Unies n'interviennent
pas.
Les forces Bosnoserbes
arrivent, séparent les hommes des femmes
et finalement tuent 8000 hommes.
Les fausses communes sont trouvées et
tout ça et finalement un certain nombre
de gens qui ont soit ordonné ces crimes,
soit commis directement, c'est je parle
des gens qui ont pointé et qui ont tiré
comme Erdemovic et d'autres seront
effectivement condamnés.
Donc
ils sont condamnés à quoi ? 7 ans
combien ?
Ça dépend ça dépend de des alors il y a
toute une échelle euh et
alors il y a un cas qui est
particulièrement intéressant.
Celui qui était des trois nationalités
c'est ça ?
C'est Dragan Erdemovic. L'histoire de
Draganerdemovic,
c'est que Draganerdemovic, il a le
mauvais âge, il a 20 ans, il veut il
vient de se marier,
sa fiancée est enceinte. Lui, il est une
famille lambda, c'est-à-dire comme
pratiquement toutes les familles,
c'est-à-dire multiraciale,
multiethnique. Lui est d'origine
croate, sa femme est d'origine
serbe et ils vivent à Sarayevo. Et comme
il vit à Sarahevo, pendant 10 jours, on
lui colle un uniforme bosniaque et et
lui tout ce qu'il veut c'est se tirer.
Donc il va finir par se tirer et il veut
aller en Suisse. qui va passer par Herz
Bosnac par la partie croate et là on lui
colle un deuxième uniforme et là aussi
il va s'en défaire pour continuer son
chemin qui passe par la République
Serbska la République serbe de
Bosnirovin et là on lui colle un trisème
uniforme et là c'est Srinitsa juillet 95
il fait partie du ploton d'exécution
il
il sera épris de remord il parlera à une
journaliste américain
et il parviendra à sortir de de
Bosnegovine et de Serbie et de et
finalement arrivera euh à la et lui
avourera ses crimes et et ses remords
donc très rapidement en en dès 96. En
fait, il
explique ça pourquoi il le fait pourquoi
pourquoi il témoignor alors lui il ce
qu'il dit euh c'est que un certain
moment il veut pas tirer et euh et
l'officier lui dit "Tu choisis ou tu vas
de l'autre côté ou tu restes de ce côté
et tu tires." Mais tu choisis.
Ce qui est vrai, c'est que ce qu'on sait
de manière documentée, c'est que les
chauffeurs
qui amené les prisonniers qui allaient
être exécutés avaient l'obligation de
tuer un seul prisonnier de manière
presque dans un système mafieux si vous
voulez pour les pour en faire des
complices du crime qui étaient en train
d'être commis. Donc donc voilà ce qui
m'a aussi frappé si on est sur cette
histoire là, il savait que par le plus
grand des hasards des années plus tard
je suis à à Sarvo
bien enfin dans les années 2000 la
guerre est finie depuis une dizaine
d'années donc c'est tout ça est très
vieux en fait et par le plus grand des
hasards là il juge dans le tribunal
hybride la la chambre des crimes de
guerre de Bosni Herzegovin il juge six
autres
personnes qui faisaient partie d'un
ploton d'exécution. Et donc, j'assiste à
ce procès et ce qui me frappe le plus,
c'est que je suis venu avec un
interprète et on est les seuls. On est
les seuls dans les rangs du public. Il
n'y a personne. Ce n'est pas filmé.
Personne ne voit cette justice en train
d'être rendue.
Alors, je me suis peut-être un peu
éloigné de de la question que vous
posiez.
On a du temps. On a du temps. Quelle
était la question ?
La question c'était le rôle de la
justice internationale. Donc à la fois,
elle me paraît essentielle
parce que la lutte contre l'impunité est
essentielle. en même temps forcé de
constater qu'il faut des conditions
politiques et de sécurité minimale pour
que cette justice puisse passer.
Il y a quelques mois
euh en Centrafrique,
il y a
un un homme qui était qui est ministre
actuellement, qui est le ministre de
l'élevage
et euh
je crois qu'il s'appelle,
je sais plus exactement, je vais pas
dire son nom parce que je viens de me
tromper. Et euh et donc la la
gendarmerie a été l'arrêtée pour parce
qu'il est accusé par le tribunal spécial
pour de la République centrafricaine qui
est un tribunal hybride donc
semi-international
de crime de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité.
Et donc il a été mis en prison et
quelques jours plus tard et bien il a
été libéré euh de par une décision
politique. Il a été réinstallé dans son
rôle de ministre et il a été décoré par
le chef de l'État.
Ce qui veut dire c'était l'un des
responsables d'un des groupes armés les
plus puissants du pays. Ce qui ce qui
veut dire en décodé, c'est que
la justice a aussi son tempôt et parfois
pour des raisons de stabilité, pour des
raisons de sécurité, elle ne veut passer
tout de suite. Moralement,
c'est très problématique. C'est très
problématique de voir
pour les victimes.
C'est très problématique pour les
victimes. C'est presque la perpétuation
du crime qui est en train d'être commis.
Surtout qu'on a des proches qui ont qui
sont morts qu'on soi-même on était
torturé. Je veux dire c'est comme si on
vous crachait la figure. Ça veut dire
c'est pire que ça quoi. Donc c'est
extraordinairement problématique
de le donc en même temps voilà il faut
qu'un qu'un certain nombre de conditions
minimales soit soit existe aujourd'hui.
Alors ce que je trouve très intéressant
pour moi et qui a un exemple que
très très riche, c'est l'Argentine.
L'Argentine, vous avez eu 30000
disparus.
1983, retour de la démocratie.
Argentine, Chili aussi.
Chili, oui, oui, oui. Chili ha dynamique
si on peut en parler si vous voulez,
mais l'Argentine 36000 disparus
euh
83, retour de la démocratie Alphantine
au pouvoir. Il décide de juger un
certain nombre de de chefs de la gunte.
les procès ont lieu et puis il veut
s'attaquer aux autres, à tous ceux qui
sont responsables de la torture et des
et de de ces dizaines de milliers de
morts. Mais l'armée commence à se
crisper et on risque un nouveau coup
d'état. Et donc finalement la démocratie
de le gouvernement démocratique décide
par prudence d'arrêter parce que les
menaces sont vraiment sérieuses. Et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il se passe que
à la place il y a une commission vérité
qui se met en place, qui va faire la
vérité.
sur sur les disparues et ça donne c'est
déjà la vérité et un des éléments de la
justice. C'est pas le seul mais çaen est
un. Et puis le temps passe, il y a des
réparations qui seront données par la
suite. C'est un deuxième élément qui
sont qui est constitutif la justice. Et
puis les années passent et puis les
équilibres politiques changent et puis
finalement la société d'Argentine change
aussi. Et finalement, la Cour suprême
dans un autre climat décide de réouvrir
sur la dossier des disparu puisque c'est
un crime continu, de réouvrir
tous ces dossiers et aujourd'hui
l'Argentine est le pays qui a le plus
jugé de torsionnaires. En d'autres
termes, pendant un certain nombre
d'années, il y avait une loi d'amnistie
mais il se fait que dès que ça a été
possible et bien cette loi d'amnistie a
été cassée. Et donc le plus vite qu'elle
soit cassée, le plus vite que les
victimes en quelque sorte ont une petite
satisfaction.
Mais par rapport à ce qui leur est
arrivé, qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est
nécessaire, c'est indispensable. Mais
quand on voit les exécutions sommaires
dans le désert d'AKama, les les gens qui
ont perdu le leur père, les veuves qui
faisaient le pied de grue tous les
samedis euh tous les weekends pour
demander.
Et donc ce qu'on voit aussi, et vous
avez raison d'insister là-dessus, c'est
le rôle de la société civile parce que
ces maères et ces grands-mères de la
place de M parce que elles étaient
toujours là, parce que d'une manière
constante, elles ont demandé des
explications au gouvernement. Elles ont
fait finalement suffisamment de pression
avec le reste de la société civile, avec
les pressions extérieures qui finalement
avec la guerre des Malouwin c'est la
guerre des Malin qui a fait finalement
tomber les généraux et qui a amené une
nouvelle un nouveau gouvernement et qui
a finalement amené à ce qu'un peu de
justice soit rendu.
Alors c'est très intéressant l'histoire
de la la guerre des Malin qu'on peut
plaquer sur tous les conflits d'ailleurs
armés. Quand on voit la guerre des
Halloween, la France fournissait des
missiles exo
quand on voit qu' des il y a des
marchands d'armes d'autres puissances
derrière qui qui fournissent à des
dictateurs ou à des à des pouvoirs peu
recommandables des armes, comment
comment on fait pour nager au milieu de
ça alors que il y a du business derrière
d'arme ? Est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
l'interdire ? Est-ce qu'il faudrait
peut-être mettre
La question est informable, je dirais.
D'abord, enfin disons la première chose
qui me vient à l'esprit, c'est c'est le
Rwanda.
C'est-à-dire qu'avec des matchettes, on
peut tuer près d'un million de personnes
en 3 mois. Donc la question de la
violence et de la cruauté appartient
sans doute à faudrait un anthropologue
ça, à l'espèce humaine malheureusement.
Alors évidemment avec une machette, on
peut on peut tuer quelques hommes à la
fois. Enfin, disons successivement alors
qu'avec une bombe nucléaire euh on en
dessus beaucoup d'un coup. Donc
effectivement ces questionslent mais
tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que
les les budgets de la défense explosent
dans tous les pays parce que tout le
monde se réarme, parce que le fond de
l'air est mauvais parce que parce que
effectivement on est rentré dans une
nouvelle configuration.
Pendant une vingtaine d'années, on a
vécu la Pax Americana, un monde
unipolaire sous hégémonie américaine et
aujourd'hui, on est dans un autre monde
avec des puissances montantes, avec le
déclin de l'Occident, avec la montée de
la Chine, du Pakistan, de l'Inde, de
l'Afrique du Sud, du Brésil, de l'Iran,
de la Turquie, d'Israël et cetera et
cetera.
Tous ces pays reconnaissent le TPI ou
pas ?
Non non non.
La Cour pénale internationale, c'est à
peu près 120 pays, 130 pays qui qui ont
qui ont qui ont qui l'ont qui ont
ratifié
ces statuts. Mais toutes les grandes
puissances, à l'exception de la France
et de la Grande-Bretagne, euh les trois
autres membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité, la Chine, les États-Unis et la
Russie, se sont bien gardés de le
signer. euh ni euh ni l'ind, ni la ni
l'Inde, ni le Pakistan, ni d'autres
pays. Euh euh dans le monde arabe, je
crois qu'il y a uniquement euh la
Jordanie et peut-être la Tunisie qui l'a
signé, mais personne d'autre. Israël ne
l'a pas signé non plus, et cetera et
cetera.
Je fais une petite diversion. Je vais
poser une question internet et je la lis
telle qu'elle est formulée. Va-t-on
aborder le sujet Bushf condolizar Tick
Chené Tony Blair et le fait qu'il ne
soit pas traîné au tribunal de la haine
pour crime de guerre sur des populations
civiles entre parenthèses jusqu'à 1,5
million de morts vous me direz ce
n'était rien. Fermez la parenthèse. des
crimes contre l'humanité avec des
fausses preuves comme la fameuse fiole
l'entraxe là la fameuse fiole où les
faux enlèvements de bébés alors c'était
pas des enlèvements c'était des des
des couveuses
des couveuses coétiennes
à la à la maternité
quand on voit ça euh
qu'il y a pas de justice parce que
c'était fausses preuves les armes de
destruction massive c'était du pipot
d'ailleurs on remercie Merci notre
ministère de d'avoir fourni des bonnes
preuves et nos services de renseignement
d'avoir fourni des bonnes preuves à nos
dirigeants.
Quand on voit que la guerre en Irak
c'était euh
Oui, tout à fait. Non mais
si aujourd'hui la Cour pénale
internationale est vue avec beaucoup de
suspicions euh par une grande partie du
monde en dehors du monde occidental,
c'est parce qu'il y a un sentiment très
profond d'injustice, de poids, de mesure
ou de pilotage
ou de pilotage ou des deux. C'est-à-dire
que même, reprenez, prenez certains
exemples. Je veux dire l'Afghanistan,
c'est un pays qui a ratifié les statuts
de la Cour pénale internationale. Il se
fait que aussi les Américains étaient
présents comme d'ailleurs les Russes et
bien d'autres. Euh il y a eu énormément
de crimes qui ont été commis.
C'est vrai que je suis un peu stupéfait
de voir le procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale se précipiter en Ukraine
alors que depuis depuis des années, il
aurait dû se lui et ses prédécesseurs
auraient dû se précipiter ou même aller
lentement en Afghanistan. Mais ils l'ont
même pas fait. Donc
l'Irak,
il y a alors l'Irak évidemment.
Évidemment. Alors euh juste une petite
parenthèse euh un peu technique, mais
euh le crime d'agression fait
aujourd'hui partie de la Cour pénale
internationale, mais il faut encore
qu'il soit expressivement euh euh
accepté. Euh il se fait que ni la Russie
ni l'Ukraine ne sont non ratifié les
statut de la Cour pénale internationale,
même si l'Ukraine a déclaré qu'elle
était compétente depuis 2014.
Maintenant, sur l'Irak, vous avez
entièrement raison. Il y a eu une
intervention militaire en dehors des
Nations- Unies sur de fausses preuves et
effectivement il n'y a eu aucun suivi
juridique. Oui,
c'est pour ça que il y a il y a des pays
qui sont suspicieux
mais c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
opinions publiques qui sont suspicieux
et parfois il y a des gouvernements qui
parfois commettent des crimes et se
retranchent aussi derrière euh
derrière un peu le sentiment d'injustice
pour se cacher eux-mêmes.
Vous avez d'autres exemples ?
Non, mais je veux dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de pays qui
à qui là ?
Non, c'est-à-dire que
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas dans un
monde de
bisous nounours là. Et euh je comprends,
c'est vrai que il est parfois
terriblement choquant et et je participe
à être choqué aussi du fait de la du
processus de de sélectivité des cas qui
sont euh pris avancés par la Cour pénale
internationale. Comme par hasard, la
Geéorgie, le cas de la Geéorgie a été
réouvert une fois que le conflit en Irak
en Irak, je raconte, en Ukraine a
commencé. Donc je trouve que la Cour
pénale internationale ne doit pas
devenir le bras armé de l'OTAN. Point
barre. C'est aussi simple que ça. Euh
quelqu'un Suisse pour dire ça [rires]
si vous voulez mais je crois pas que je
je crois pas que je suis le seul quand
même. Donc loin de là. Heureusement
qu'on est encore la Suisse.
Mais non, encore heureux qu'il y a qu'il
y a une société civile active dans
beaucoup de pays et qui dit des choses
importantes. Et donc non, je crois que
et je crois que la question des
exigences est importante, exigence de
justice et
c'est et si on refait un peu l'histoire
recul de la Cour pénale internationale,
on voit que c'était les sociétés civiles
africaines qui voulaient euh la Cour
pénale internationale parce que elles
n'avaient pas confiance dans leur propre
justice.
Malheureusement, la Cour pénale
internationale n'a jugé que des
africains et donc elle n'a fait qu'une
partie très sélective de son travail et
donc
elle a jugé aussi un peu les pays de
l'Est.
Elle a jugé personne à ce jour qui ne
soit pas africain.
Euh la Cour pénale internationale, si
vous parlez du tribunal pénal
international pour l'exoslavie are
tribunal. Excusez-moi, j'ai fait le
Je vous laisse continuer.
Non non non non. Voilà, j'ai fini.
Je vais prendre une question internet.
Un soldat qui obéit aux ordres d'abattre
des civils est-il coupable ?
Le le soldat est évidemment coupable de
de crime de guerre. La question qui se
pose ensuite, c'est est-ce qu'il y a eu
une chaîne de commandement ? Euh il y a
eu un cas, si vous voulez assez je pense
un cas très précis en fait. Euh il y a
eu un un soldat égyptien euh qui était
sur la frontière au Sinaï et qui a tué
des des civils, des touristes
israéliens. Euh je dire l'Égypte n'était
pas en guerre avec Israël, c'était un
soldat qui simplement a pété les plombs,
quoi. Donc c'est quelque chose de
totalement différent quand il y a une
chaîne de commandement où il y a des
ordres qui ont été donnés. Et donc après
la question qui se pose, est-ce que
c'est une attaque systématique
ou est-ce que c'est une troupe
particulière et cetera et cetera et voir
jusqu'où monte le degré la chaîne de
commandement et ensuite quels ont été
les processus qui ont été mis en place
une fois que le crime a été commis.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu une ouverture d'une
enquête ou pas par l'armée en question ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu un suivi ? Est-ce
qu'il y a des gens qui ont été
réprimandés ? quelle a été la la
l'attitude des officiers et cetera et
cetera. Quand vous dites une troupe
particulière, ça ça fait référence à à
aussi à ce qui s'est passé en Ukraine
quand en 2014 Amnistie Internationale,
Amnestie belge disait il faudrait quand
même calmer un petit peu vos commandants
du vos commandau d'ultrationaliste parce
qu'ils font quand même des choses un peu
compliquées [grognement]
sans rentrer dans tous les détails.
Est-ce qu'à chaque fois, dans chaque
conflit, il y a des commandos d'ultra
radicalisés qui vont faire se faire
justice selon leur propre idéologie et
le pouvoir central qui s'appuyait quand
même un peu là-dessus, ferme un peu les
yeux, tourne la tête et attend que ça se
dilue.
Déjà, ce qui je trouve très enfin très
inquiétant aujourd'hui, c'est la
privatisation de la guerre.
Euh
je veux dire que aujourd'hui enfin les
Britanniques avaient une longue
tradition qui remonte presque au au 19e
siècle où ils ont utilisé des des
notamment des des népalés pour un
certain nombre
les gourkas. Exactement. Et et donc il y
a il y a des
le vous parlez à un Suisse d'ailleurs,
la question du mercenariat n'est pas
nouveau et et donc vous le savez bien
mais ce que au quoi on assiste
aujourd'hui euh c'est aussi bien dans
les pays occidentaux aux États-Unis,
c'est qu'un nombre de de gens qui
portent des des uniformes sont employés
par des sociétés militaires privées.
Attendez, j'ouvre juste une parenthèse,
j'ai un doute. Vous êtes sûr que c'est
les Népalés, les gourcassent pas
libérement je me trompe peut-être. Euh
je crois que c'est des Népalés. Mais
Népal, vous avez raison. Ouais. Ou c'est
ceux c'est ceux qui ont le couteau un
peu euh en forme de boomerang. C'est ça.
Écoutez, j'ai pas vérifié la forme, leur
couteau, mais euh et puis sans doute euh
Google nous renseignera mieux que ce que
je dirais, mais euh
mais je sais plus où j'en suis.
Je vous ai coupé le le mercenariat, la
priorité.
Le mercenariat. Alors oui, évidemment et
on a vu notamment en Irak pour venir à
l'Irak que très souvent c'était des
soldats employés par des sociétés
militaires privées qui avaient commis
des exactions et qui n'avaient pas en
fait la question qui se posait était une
question de droit aussi c'estàd de qui à
qui ils étaient responsables en fait
parce qu'il y a pas vraiment de chaîne
de commandement comme dans une armée
classique et donc aujourd'hui on
effectivement il y a des guidelines qui
ont été élaborés pour essayer de de
mettre un peu de droit dans cette dans
ces guerres qui sont de plus en plus
privatisées. On le voit très bien aussi
avec Wagner, que ça soit en Ukraine ou
que ça soit au Mali par exemple. Afrique
quand vous parlez des sociétés
militaires privées, on va prendre
l'exemple de de l'Irak, vous avez été en
Irak.
J'étais en Irak. Quand vous voyez ces
sociétés militaires privées ayant des
droits régaliens,
la population en face ne peut que se
radicaliser, non ?
Oui.
Quel regard vous portez sur les les
prisons d'Abou Graïb de Guantanamo
le processus de d'incarcération à
l'américaine ? C'est les c'est le
business qui était fait autour de ça.
C'était nécessaire, c'était pas
nécessaire ? Est-ce que ces gens vont
être jugés ? Est-ce que les gens qui ont
industrialisé la torture,
je vous laisserai ?
Alors, c'est une question tellement
riche. D'abord, la première chose et ça
fait penser presque au titre du bouquin
quoi, négocier avec le diable et surtout
comment on crée des diables. Et c'est
vrai qu'après le 11 septembre, on a créé
cette image effectivement du euh du
terroriste. Alors, je dis pas il y a eu
3000 morts, il s'agit pas de faire du
négationnisme ici en aucune manière.
C'est dire les attentats du 11 septembre
ont eu lieu, c'était particulièrement
horrible et cetera et cetera. Donc ce
que mais euh mais c'est vrai que par la
suite, il y a eu une volonté presque de
revanche et de diabolisation de ces
groupes armés djihadistes et qui et dont
les membres même sur simple
suspicion, merci, euh ont été parfois
euh euh torturés et en particulier à
Aboub.
Ensuite
suspicion par dé
par délaation. Ensuite un certain nombre
il y a eu euh Guantanamo et alors ce qui
s'est passé à Guantanamo, c'est quand
même formidablement à la fois
intéressant et inquiétant. C'est-à-dire
que le système judiciaire américain ne
vous ne pouvait pas juger ces gens qui
ont été tellement torturés puisque les
preuves enfin ont été obtenues sous la
torture et donc c'était pas recevable
par un système démocratique et donc ils
n'ont jamais été jugés. Il y a eu
quelques tentatives de justice militaire
en Guantanamo même mais selon des règles
tellement absurdes euh que c'était une
sorte de Frankenstein judiciaire qui a
été créée en Guatanamo. Il y a eu euh
quelques un certain nombre d'avocats
ont raconté comment ça se passait. Mais
c'est c'est même pas dire c'est même
c'est même pas une justice militaire.
C'est ça marche sur la tête
véritablement.
De tous ces conflits que vous avez
suivi, quel quel était pour vous les
pires sévices et les pires torture ?
Écoutez, je sais pas la question du
palmarès, c'est quelque chose que
Qu'est-ce qui vous a fait le qui vous a
fait les cauchemars ? Je vous donne un
exemple. Ouais.
Moi en Syrie c'était Daesh qui torturait
les homosexuels, qui les balança du 7e
étage. Et j'ai quelque chose qui me
reste en tête, c'est le cri de l'homme
qui voit la mort se rapprocher.
Oui.
Écoutez, c'est une question qui qui
m'embarrasse he parce c'est je veux dire
mettre des des palmarèses de l'horreur.
Tout ce que je peux dire c'est que il y
a des expériences qui m'ont profondément
marqué. Oui. Euh je suis arrivé sur un
lieu d'un massacre dans les balcans
parmi l'un des premiers. C'était j'en ai
porté le souvenir longtemps et j'en
porte le souvenir dès que je l'évoque.
Euh
j'étais euh après le génocide très très
rapidement après le génocide au Rwanda,
l'odeur de la mort était des ossements
partout était inqualifiable. Euh non, il
y a voilà quoi. Mais
je crois qu'il faut pas rentrer dans il
faut voir l'étincelle de vie dans chacun
de nous. Euh il faut réfléchir comment
comment vivre, comment avoir du plaisir,
comment avoir du comment reconstruire,
comment faire avec comment faire avec
tout ce qui s'est passé et comment
comment être des réapprendre à être des
hommes et des femmes, réapprendre à être
soi, réapprendre à aimer tout
simplement. Et je crois que c'est
vraiment sur ça qu'il faut regarder.
Comment on fait pour apprendre à à aimer
et réapprendre à aimer alors que son
voisin vous a coupé en morceau, vous a
poursuivi, vous a bombardé la gueule,
vous a fait les les pires choses.
Comment on fait pour réapprendre à aimer
?
Écoutez, c'est des questions très très
personnelles qui et j'ai vu des choses
très très différentes dans ma vie et et
je juge rien en fait. Je m'abstiens de
juger.
J'ai vu des gens, pas beaucoup, très peu
en fait, mais qui ont pardonné à des à
des gens qui ont tué toute leur famille
au Rwanda
parce que pour vivre, ils avaient besoin
de pardonner.
Je encore une fois, j'en ai vu j'ai vu
ailleurs d'autres personnes qui étaient
dans la haine et la colère, d'autres qui
étaient qui avaient des soif de justice.
Et puis j'ai surtout vu aussi, je me
souviens de d'une femme qui qui avait
adopté un enfant qui avait survécu au
génocide et dont les parents étaient
morts. et et donc
et une autre qui me disait qui avait
échappé à la mort et qui était enceinte
et elle disait "C'est enfant que je
porte en moi, il en a déjà trop vu."
Mais je crois que il faut regarder du
côté de la vie, donc du côté de la
jeunesse, de l'enfance
et et en même temps être en même temps
dans l'affiliation, dans pas dans le
déni, pas pas dans l'oubli, dans la
mémoire, mais du côté de la vie.
question internet. Euh
demande-lui euh demande-lui comment
négocier avec les Russes en/ Poutine
actuellement ce qu'il conseille son
expertise.
Si seulement si j'avais une baguette
magique. Non mais je
crois que ce qui
tout à l'heure on parlait des
différentes des différentes négociations
qui ont eu lieu en Ukraine, les trois
qui ont eu lieu sur les céréales. Vous
savez que que les l'accord sur les
céréales doit durer 120 jours en théorie
uniquement et en plus il peut être cassé
n'importe quand. Donc la question
effectivement c'est qu'est-ce qui va se
passer à ces précé 120 jours ? Donc
l'une des choses, c'est on peut espérer
une renégociation pour le prolonger,
que les échanges de prisonniers
continuent,
que qui est de plus en plus d'accord
pour essayer de d'empêcher l'escalade
avec le nucléaire, de protéger les
centrales nucléaires beaucoup mieux,
d'enlever les armes le lourdes. Donc
essayez après d'identifier
des points très précis où vous pouvez
intervenir tant que les deux parties ne
sont pas prêtes à entamer une discussion
de fond. sur le règlement du conflit.
Visiblement aujourd'hui, on est dans
l'escalade, on n'est pas dans on on
n'est pas dans la désescalade. On est
encore dans des dégradations où et on
voit comment le les discours évoluent,
on voit comment les armes évoluent et et
tout ça est terriblement inquiétant.
Mais je crois que le rôle dans les de
chaque processus de paix est de faire le
mapping le plus complet possible et de
voir effectivement quels sont les points
très précis d'intervention. Euh parfois
ça peut être restitué des corps, parfois
c'est des choses assez assez limitées
mais pour les gens qui en voient le
bénéfice c'est énorme.
Vous parlez des accords faire respecter
les accords. La Russie a pas respecté
les accords de Budapest. L'Ukraine a pas
respecté les accords de MISK. Les
accords personne ne les respecte. Et on
en arrive à cette situation là.
Comment on fait pour faire respecter des
accords ? Surtout que la France était
censée être garante d'une partie des
accords. Comment on fait pour faire
respecter des accords ? On est au 21e
siècle. En Europe, ça se castagne en
fait. Peut-être que l'humanité n'est pas
faite pour s'accorder et qu'on est
condamné à se taper dessus.
Bah de toute manière, je crois qu'il
suffit de voir une cour de récréation et
ce qui s'y passe pour voir ce qu'il en
est quelque part de la nature humaine à
une toute petite échelle.
Les hommes sont méchants,
mais ils ont tout. Ils sont méchants,
ils sont bons, ils sont géniaux, ils
sont c'est des salopards à certains
moments et parfois ça peut être les
deux, vous savez. Et donc oui, on est
tous
les accords. Comment on fait pour faire
respecter les accords ? Alors la
question des alors justement là disons
ce la question c'est une question en
fait qui est une question très je dirais
géopolitique.
C'est-à-dire que lorsque on est dans la
séquence de l'unipolarité américaine,
c'est-à-dire les années 90 pour faire
court et un peu au-delà
quand c'est à ce moment-là, les années
90,
vous avez une plétor d'accord de paix.
Mais une plétéor, c'est les Nations
Unies qui les font essentiellement, mais
pas seulement. Mais et vous avez vous
avez le Cambodge, vous avez Salvador,
vous avez le Guatemala, vous en avez
plein durant les années 90. Pourquoi ?
parce que vous avez un parrain, parce
que vous avez les Nations- Unies et
qu'il y a une stabilité et une sécurité
des normes et des valeurs qui sont plus
ou moins respectées, même si la Bosnie
et le Rwanda par ailleurs et d'autres
choses aussi. Maintenant, on est rentré
dans une autre séquence et cette autre
séquence, c'est un monde multipolaire,
beaucoup plus dangereux, beaucoup plus
fragmenté. On n'est pas d'accord sur les
normes, on n'est pas d'accord sur les
valeurs et donc effectivement on est
rentré dans un monde beaucoup plus
dangereux et donc les accords ce seront
souvent des accords transactionnels. Et
l'accord sur le blé par exemple est un
accord transactionnel. Donc ça va il
éviter une famine en Afrique, c'est
super important. Euh il y a et l'Ukraine
et la Russie qui vont avoir un peu de
devises qui vont rentrer. Et bien il
faut faut s'en féliciter. Les gens vont
éviter de mourir parce qu'il y a eu cet
accord.
Question internet. [soupir]
Bonsoir l'équipe. Une question de Cap.
Euh avec le rapport de la de l'ordre
mélien, de la force mélien ou mélienne,
peut-on réellement discuter ? Une
négociation est-elle toujours possible
ou c'est une chimère ? L'ordre mélien,
ça vous parle ? H
non,
c'est plus vous êtes balaise, plus vous
avez raison
pour résumer trivialement les choses.
D'accord. Euh non, il y a des euh Non,
la le dialogue n'est pas toujours
possible. Euh je prends un exemple, un
groupe armé, par exemple, je pense pas
que le sentier lumineux était ouvert au
dialogue.
Le sentier lumineux pour que les gens
comprennent
au Pérou. Euh est-ce que l'organisation
de l'État islamique est ouvert au
dialogue ? Je pense pas qu'elle soit
ouvert au dialogue, mais elle a accepté
que de l'aide humanitaire puisse
parvenir
aux populations qu'elle contrôle ou
qu'elle oui qu'elle contrôle. Donc elle
a accepté un dialogue minimal pour ça en
ce sens. Voilà, c'est un petit plus.
Question de Lara. Il y a quelques
minutes l'invité a parlé du rôle de la
diaspora dans les conflits modernes. On
entend régulièrement l'UDC entre
parenthèses, il saura de quoi je parle,
tenir des propos totalement irrationnels
sur le sujet. Cependant, je serais
curieux d'avoir un avis éclairé sur ce
sujet. La question de Lara. Oui, la
question c'est sur les diasporas et
c'est vrai que il y a dans beaucoup de
diaspora un sentiment tout à fait
compréhensible, c'est d'être de
de vouloir soutenir sa patrie d'origine
et d'autres d'être encore plus
légitimiste ou plus loyau que les gens
là-bas eux-mêmes. Et souvent ce qui se
passe qu'à travers notamment les réseaux
sociaux, ils vont alimenter une sorte de
caisse de résonance qui va prendre de
plus en plus d'importance et qui va
contribuer à faire monter les émotions.
Et en ce sens-là, c'est un premier
danger. Le deuxième danger, c'est que
les diasporas souvent elles vont aussi
contribuer à à financer des filières
d'armes pour alors parfois pour
défendre, mais chacun se pose toujours
dans une position défensive. Et donc
souvent les diasporas euh ont un effet
effectivement de euh disons de tension
supplémentaire.
Les médias, vous êtes journaliste.
GT
GT. Vous avez quel regard sur les médias
en temps de guerre ?
Euh bon, ça fait ça fait une vingtaine
d'années que je suis plus journaliste.
Je faut que je
On reste toujours journaliste quand on
l'a été. Non, c'est un peu comme
gendarme. [rires]
Je sais pas, j'ai jamais été gendarme.
Euh
non, les les médias sont essentiels,
mais c'est sûr que c'est un paramètre
dans un conflit. Euh et euh et les les
billégérants le savent formidablement
bien et donc vont tout faire pour les
instrumentaliser.
la responsabilité éthique enfin
j'insiste beaucoup dans mon bouquin sur
la responsabilité éthique du médiateur
mais là je pense que par les s'agissant
des médias il y a une responsabilité
éthique du journaliste qui est énorme
parce que il doit il doit effectivement
essayer d'être au plus près des des
faits et c'est pas un travail facile. La
question d'établir
la d'établir les faits et je pense à un
exemple très très précis en fait. Euh
non non, un exemple où j'étais impliqué
en fait. Euh
euh je suis arrivé justement, je parlais
tout à l'heure d'un des lieux de
massacre auquel j'ai je suis arrivé très
rapidement et il se fait que c'était au
Kosovo
et il y avait il y avait une quarantaine
de corps dans dans un village. Mais ce
qui était important, c'était que cette
résonance à ce moment-là de ce massacre
allait peut-être déclencher une
intervention militaire.
Donc j'ai vu en l'espace de qu de
quelques heures à peine quatre
machines de propagande se mettre en
marche
presque sous mes yeux quoi. Et alors
qu'on était encore, j'étais sur les
lieux sur place, on était encore en
train de de tomber sur les corps, de les
voir de voir les corps et certains
c'était c'était pas beau.
Euh
et euh
et pardon, je du coup je vois les images
qui reviennent. Il y a souci
et euh et donc pour euh pour pour
Lcheka, il fallait dire qu'il y avait un
maximum de victimes et qu'il y avait des
enfants qui avaient été tués. Pour les
Serbes, il fallait dire que évidemment
il n'y avait que c'était uniquement des
soldats et qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de
victimes. Et les Français qui voulait
absolument avoir une négociation
diplomatique à Paris voulait euh ne
voulait pas une confrontation militaire
et les Américains étaient déjà lancés
quelque part dans la volonté de
d'intervenir militairement. Donc en
l'espace de quelques heures, vous vous
étiez abreuvé finalement euh de de
machines de propagande qui vous voulez
faire vous faire écrire quelque chose.
Et c'est vrai qu'on était un nombre
restreint de journalistes sur place, on
était peut-être au maximum, je sais pas
10 15 et que à ce moment-là ça avait une
importance.
Comment vous voyez l'avenir par exemple
soit au Moyen-Orient en Afrique avec le
réchauffement climatique, la crise
énergétique, la crise des migrants ? la
crise financière, l'effondrement des
monnaies, le fait que les dettes
souveraines vont risque de se faire
attaquer. Cette tension montée
de votre expérience, est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on va vers une une résolution
des conflits beaucoup plus pacifistes
pacifiques où en fait on est en fin de
partie, ça va partir en quenouille.
Vous êtes un cran optimiste, je crois.
Peut-être réaliste. Réaliste. J'achète
pas mes lunettes roses en Suisse.
[rires]
Écoutez, moi non plus j'achète pas des
lunettes rose et je suis d'accord en
Suisse
et je je suis d'accord que je suis
d'accord que la situation est sérieuse
et très sérieuse.
Euh ce qui me frappe, parlons du Sahel 2
minutes si vous voulez bien.
Au Sahel, d'abord la situation est
est est très très grave et il faut se
remettre un peu dans dans la séquence
des événements. D'abord, nous avons nous
avons ce qui se passe en Libye. Il y a
l'intervention de l'OTAN en Libye et qui
a
sous quelle résolution de quel droit
international ? Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? On apporte la démocratie pour
les petites filles encore. On va
protéger des populations. On est censé
maîtriser l'espace aérien.
Vous m'emmenez vous m'emmenez très loin.
Mais OK. Euh c'est alors euh la
résolution c'est la seule fois qu'elle a
été utilisée et après les Russes vont la
bloquer sans doute pour toujours. C'est
la responsabilité de protéger.
C'est-à-dire que si on fait un retour en
arrière, euh il y a eu pendant pendant
les années 90 après notamment la Bosnie
et le Rwanda, il y a eu tout un
processus de réflexion en se disant
"Mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
éviter que ça se reproduise ?
Que les populations civiles soient
massacrées."
Exactement. Et donc il y a eu et donc en
France il y avait toute la question du
droit d'ingérence et
finalement le droit d'ingérence a été
complètement retourné et mis sur sur sa
je sais pas sur ses pieds ou sur sa tête
je sais pas exactement et pour pour
créer un autre concept qui est la
responsabilité de protéger c'està-dire
que les États ont la responsabilité de
protéger leur propre population mais
maintenant s'ils ne le font pas s'ils
même attaque leur population. Alors à ce
moment-là, la communauté internationale
a un devoir de solidarité à l'égard des
populations et donc peut intervenir mais
en dernier ressort. C'est donc ça le
concept de de la opie, la responsabilité
de protéger et donc c'est et donc elle a
été utilisée. Il y a donc une résolution
des Nations- Unies du Conseil de
sécurité.
Medvedev a accepté, il est président à
ce moment-là, c'est pas Poutine. Poutine
est premier ministre. Medvedev a accepté
même de de dire au Chinois, on s'abtient
ce couplà. Ça a l'air très sérieux ce
qui se passe en Libye et tout à coup
donc intervention de l'OTAN et
finalement les Russes et les Chinois ont
l'impression de ça te fait avoir puisque
en fait ils assistent à un changement de
régime et pas tellement à une
responsabilité de protéger d'une
population qui n'est plus qui n'a plus
besoin d'être protégée à ce moment-là.
Et donc
le régime tombe et ce qui aura des
incidences énormes en Syrie avec la
responsabilité protégée puisqu'elle sera
plus jamais utilisée. Mais maintenant
pour parler du Sahel, ce qui se passe
c'est qu'une partie de de l'armement
considérable de de Kaddafi va esséer
dans tout le Sahel et donc va alimenter
les groupes armés.
2012, vous avez l'intervention vous avez
euh une alliance entre les
indépendantistes du Nord Mali qui
veulent créer la Zawad et ça sera la 5e
rébellion des Touareg euh avec des
djihadistes qui commencent qu'à prendre
à prendre euh Kid euh Kidal Gao,
Tambukou intervention française et euh
et vous connaissez la suite. surtout je
connais surtout le proverbe du Sud Mali
qui dit pour reprocher à la zawad quand
tu te couches avec le diable le
lendemain matin tu sens encore le diable
ils ont jamais pardonné les accords de
de la zawad des toeg avec Al-Qaïda
jamais
non ouais non tout à fait donc ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
au Sahel c'est plusieurs phénomènes qui
se surrajoutent c'est C'est pour ça que
c'est si compliqué et si grave. D'une
part, vous avez tout premier facteur,
c'est tous ces armes qui étaient en
Libye qui ont essé dans toute la région.
Deuxième facteur, vous avez très peu de
ressources, c'est des pays super
pauvres, mais vous avez une démographie
qui est énorme, la plus haute de la
planète. Vous avez au Niger 7,3 enfants
par femme. C'est-à-dire qu'une femme qui
a 20 ans en au Niger aujourd'hui a déjà
5 enfants. Euh au Mali, vous avez 6,8
enfants de moyenne par femme. Donc une
une croissance démographique très
importante qui provoque une tension très
très forte sur les ressources. Ensuite,
vous avez évidemment les groupes les
groupes islamistes qui euh qui mettent
qui qui limitent les terres à par leur
intervention les terres les terres
arables.
Et vous avez des États qui sont euh où
la mauvaise gouvernance prime et souvent
dans les zones périphériques,
dire corruption, hein,
on peut dire ça. Et donc
et donc
les les biens comme l'éducation, la
santé et cetera
non dans les zones périphériques
n'existent pas. Donc vous avez
finalement tous les facteurs pour créer
des tensions entre des communautés qui
sont rivales et qui se battent pour très
très peu de ressources finalement. Et
vous avez en gros pour simplifier à
l'extrême deux types de communautés.
Vous avez les communautés qui sont
semi-nomades et qui sont essentiellement
des éleveurs comme les PE et de l'autre
côté, vous avez des des des sociés qui
sont sédentaires et qui sont des des
cultivateurs. Et donc avec en plus le
changement climatique, les traditionnels
couloirs de transhumance sont remis en
question et donc vous avez énormément
vous avez en fait des centaines de
conflits aujourd'hui dans la bande
saélienne entre les différentes
communautés. qui se dispute
effectivement l'accès aux ressources,
l'accès aux puits, l'accès aux couloirs,
l'accès aux terres arables. Et donc d'un
côté, vous avez un premier conflit entre
les groupes djihadistes et l'État. Et
puis en dessous, mais instrumentalisé et
par l'État et par les groupes
djihadistes, vous avez des dizaines, des
centaines de conflits armés entre
communautés qui chacune crée leur milice
pour s'autodéfendre.
Donc avec le réchauffement climatique,
l'affaiblissement de de la monnaie, le
toutes les crise en train de se
profiler, ça va jamais s'arranger.
Est-ce que vous pensez
Non, mais alors ce qui est super
intéressant aujourd'hui, c'est que il y
a des processus de médiation qui sont
qui
existent et et en fait qui sont des
processus de médiation qui plongent leur
racine dans l'histoire quasiment.
immémorial de ces régions-là.
C'est-à-dire que la médiation, le
dialogue font partie aussi des cultures
saéliennes. Et donc je travaille pour
une organisation notamment
s'appelle comment ? le Centre pour le
dialogue humanitaire qui a qui avec ses
équipes uniquement locales, j'insiste le
sur le mot uniquement local, qui a
participé à faire une cinquantaine euh
d'accords de paix ou de prévention de
conflit entre des communautés euh au
Mali, au Burkina Faso, au Niger, en
Mauritanie
et donc
je pense que à petite échelle c'est
possible de stabiliser
certaines zones géographiques et de
trouver des moyens d'entendre sur la
répartition des ressources parce que
c'est vraiment ça. Et donc dès que vous
arrivez un peu à stabiliser, dès que
vous arrivez et parfois ces processus de
dialogue, c'est 300 personnes qui
pendant des jours discutent entre eux,
c'estd c'est un dialogue saélien selon
les us et coutumes locales. Et donc
finalement, il y a des processus après
il y a un comité de suivi qui se met en
place et donc ça permet de de stabiliser
de manière modeste, de manière humble
certaines zones géographiques entre
différentes communautés. Tout ça est
formidablement fragile. Je suis le
premier à le dire mais au moins ça
existe. Ça veut dire que oui, il y a
quand même des choses qui sont possible.
Après, c'est dans quel mesure ces choses
qui sont possibles, on peut arriver à
une plus grande échelle. Et on voit un
discours qui évolue pendant très
longtemps. Le discours
des gouvernements saéliens, notamment
poussé par la France, mais aussi par le
C'est pas une erreur ça. Est-ce qu'il
faut pas laisser les pays africains
régler leurs problèmes, arrêter de les
de les pousser à gauche à droite ou leur
donner X Y plus de plus ? Est-ce que
l'Afrique est pas suffisamment mature
pour régler ses problèmes ? Mais
l'exemple des médiations euh même si
c'est une organisation qu'il fait qui
est occidentale en fait c'est tous les
gens qui travaillent sur ces
processus-là sont tous des saéliens.
Donc c'est des gens locaux qui parlent
au leur donc c'était des solutions
africaines pour des problèmes africains.
Oui, tout à fait. Et on voit comment
pendant très longtemps les pays
occidentaux mais aussi les les
gouvernements locaux ont
mis tout l'accent sur la lutte
antiterroriste
en alors que
pourquoi vous faites antiterroriste
entre guillemets ? Est-ce que ça alors
ça ouvre un autre débat euh qui est un
débat riche et compliqué, c'est comment
se fabrique les listes deorganisations
terroristes ? Mais vous m'empêchez de
répondre à la question précédente.
Non, je vous en prie. Finissez la
première question puis on on
Mais je me souviens plus de la première
maintenant
sur le fait que l'Afrique peut
Oui, tout à fait. Euh donc
on voit aujourd'hui une évolution alors
qui n'est pas synchrone avec au Mali. Il
y a eu deux coups d'état récemment au
Burkina Faso, il y a eu un nouveau coup
d'état. Donc on ne sait pas donc on voit
comment ces pays aujourd'hui euh ces
sociétés sont elles-mêmes partagées en
trois modèles de société pour faire
cours. D'un côté, vous avez le modèle
euh autoritaire à l'égyptienne en fait.
De l'autre côté, vous avez le modèle
libéral hérité de la colonisation. Et
troisièmement, vous avez le modèle en
gros salafiste de cratique. Donc ces
sociétés aujourd'hui sont tiraillé entre
les populations sont tiraillé entre ces
trois modèles de société et les
gouvernements à différents moments font
différents choix. Et depuis 2018, on
voit qu'à certains moments, certains
gouvernements ont tendu la main à
certains groupes armé salafiste euh et
puis ça a avancé, ça a pas avancé mais
et on voit aussi non pas tellement en
France mais plutôt à Bruxelles et et
même aux Nations- Unies puisque le
secrétaire général des Nations- Unies a
dit que certains groupes armés avaient
vocation à devenir des organisations
politiques euh Et donc on voit comment
le discours est en train de changer
parce que finalement ces groupes armés
depuis que la lutte antiterroriste
soi-disant devait les éradiquer n'a fait
que prospérer et que aujourd'hui il
contrôle une partie importante du
territoire.
Donc la deuxième question, la guerre
contre le terrorisme entre guillemets,
pourquoi ça vous a fait réagir ? Non,
mais parce que euh parce que est
terroriste celui qu'on nomme terroriste
en fait et donc
on a c'est flagrant quand même hein.
Oui.
Mais euh c'est-à-dire que il y a eu euh
une résolution, je pense que c'est la
euh mais à vérifier mais je pense
qu'elle est juste euh qui
euh et d'autres résolutions qui euh des
Nations- Unies qui incitent à lutter
contre le terrorisme et c'est qui et qui
ont différents effets très concrets. Le
premier le premier effet, c'est qu'il
s'agit d'isoler et d'éradiquer les ce
qu'on considère comme des groupes armés
terroristes ou les personnes
terroristes. Et donc à partir de là, la
médiation même ou l'aide humanitaire
n'est plus possible puisquil faut isoler
ces gens-là. Donc ça pose énormément de
problèmes pour des organisations de
médiation parce que théoriquement on n'a
pas le droit de rentrer en contact avec
elle-même.
Aujourd'hui, la réalité du monde fait
qu'on est dans un monde de plus en plus
gris et la réalité du monde fait que
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
gouvernement
sont prêts à financer ou à sous-traiter
des dialogues avec des groupes armés
parce qu'elles considèrent que on ne
peut pas simplement tenir sur une ligne
antiterroriste, mais il faut aussi
ouvrir le dialogue avec des groupes
armés. Le fait que les les gouvernements
financent euh ces groupes de dialogue,
ça peut aussi être préjudiciable dans le
sens où certaines ONG en Afrique euh ne
peuvent plus se balader tranquillement
parce que elles sont suspectées d'être
infiltré par des services de
renseignement ou d'être financé par le
gouvernement qui a peut-être déstabilisé
le pays pour ses propres intérêts
financiers. Est-ce que ça c'est pas
problématique ? Est-ce que c'est pas la
société civile [soupir]
d'aller protéger d'autres civils et de
faire en dehors des gouvernements ?
Écoutez, dans un monde idéal, idéal,
oui, sûrement. Euh simplement euh c'est
vrai que pour euh les médiateurs locaux,
souvent ils sont peuvent se trouver pris
dans des situations
terriblement compliquées où ils peuvent
être soupçonnés d'un côté d'être des
traîtres à leur communauté et de l'autre
côté d'être perçu comme des espions
alors que ils n'essayent que de
minimiser les souffrances et de d'ouvrir
les voies du dialogue. Oui. Donc c'est
potentiellement dangereux. Oui, et
certains l'ont payé de leur vie.
Je vais je vais être un peu provoque.
Vous avez suivi les gilets jaunes ?
Enfin, j'ai lu dans les journaux. Oui.
Donc, mouvement contestataire en France
réclamant des solutions politiques. Les
Suisses avaient-il le devoir d'ingérence
pour aller protéger la population
française ? Parce que selon les Suisses,
les LBD40, c'est des armes de guerre.
Et donc si je comprends bien les
Suisses, la Suisse a vu la France tirer
à l'arme de guerre sur sa population.
Est-ce qu'il fallait faire quelque chose
?
Écoutez, je vois mal je vois mal les
casques bleus suisses arrivés en France.
Euh
je crois que la Suisse a ses propres
problèmes avec l'Union européenne et
donc elle se garderait bien d'intervenir
sur ces tels sujets que ça soit avec la
France, que ça soit avec l'Allemagne,
que ça soit un autre pays européen, elle
a pas signé les bilatérales. Donc elle a
énormément de problèmes avec l'Union
européenne. Donc elle va être très très
tourner la tête.
Elle va Exactement, elle va tourner la
tête. non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures d'un d'un pays. Euh
maintenant
euh c'est sûr que chaque pays a des
traditions policières différentes et la
tradition française visiblement est très
très musclée.
[soupir] Euh la diplomatie
c'est il y en a plus. Ça on est où la
diplomatie mondiale ? Ça reste que un un
petit cercle de personnes ayant atterri
dans des salons feutrés avec des
moquettes de 3 cm d'épaisseur ne servant
plus à grand-chose
ou servant à grand-chose ou ou qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les diplomates ? Par
exemple, la diplomatie française pour
vous, comment vous la jugez ? Est-ce que
c'est une une diplomatie de façade ?
Est-ce que elle a perdu ses racines ?
Est-ce que la diplomatie suisse n'est
pas Quand on voit Nathalie Liseau créer
un un scandale diplomatique avec la
Suisse ? Il faut quand même le faire
créer un scandale diplomatique avec la
Suisse.
On en est où avec la diplomatie ?
C'est une question tellement énorme. Euh
écoutez, la diplomatie c'est simplement
essayer de
dire sans diplomatie où serait le monde
? Je veux dire, c'est simplement l'acte
de parler
et entre gens qui sont de pays différent
et pour essayer de s'entendre. Donc je
pense qu'elle est plus essentielle que
jamais. Je vous prends, donnez-moi, je
crois que c'est important de revenir à
des exemples super concret. Donne ce que
vous voulez, on a tout notre temps.
D'accord.
Écoutez euh [raclement de gorge]
bah Gutures le patron de l'ONU a une
bonne idée. C'est de dire quand il y a
le Covid, la pandémie, il dit "Ben
proclamons un cesser le feu
mondial."
Ça s'est pas passé. Mais ceci dit, il y
a eu un certain nombre de
dans plusieurs pays, je pense notamment
à la Centrafrique, à au Soudan, à la
Colombie où l'État et le gouvern et le
gouvernement ont décidé de trêve. Euh,
ils ont pas voulu l'appeler cesser le
feu parce que souvent cesser le feu
donne une légitimité mais ils l'ont
appelé trêve. Mais les armes se sont
tues de manière à ce que pouvoir
vacciner des populations dans des zones
dans des zones en conflit. Donc vous
voyez, je veux dire de manière très
super concrète, je crois qu'il faut pas
euh essayer de de rêver à une sorte de
paix mondiale ou de monde idéal. Il faut
revenir sur le plancher des vaches et
essayer de manière très concrète
d'identifier les problèmes et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire à ce moment-là. Je
crois que ça s'arrête là. Et donc si on
peut faire quelque chose, faisons-le.
Est-ce que vous voulez aborder un sujet
qu'on a pas encore abordé ensemble ?
Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui vous
touche à cœur ? Est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui qui est nécessaire pour la
population civile, pour notre communauté
de comprendre ou de s'intéresser ?
Moi ce qui peut-être j'aimerais revenir
un peu au déclencheur de mon livre en
fait.
Euh
comment il s'appelle votre livre ?
Négocier avec le diable.
Je peux vous couper avant ? Ouais.
Quand on voit certaines populations
civiles dans les propres États
occidentaux,
s'interdire de discuter ou de juger ceux
qui discutent avec le entre guillemets
le camp d'en face quand ils appliquent
une pureté idéologique, quand ils
s'estiment détenteur de la pureté
idéologique en disant
"Vous discutez avec le diable, donc vous
êtes le diable, vous n'avez pas le droit
de discuter avec les autres parce qu'ils
sont sales, ils sont pas beaux ou ils
sont bon je caricature.
Quand vous voyez ça dans notre propre
population, ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
Est-ce que on va vers une guerre civile
? Est-ce que c'est les prémisses d'une
guerre civile ? Oui, c'est les c'est les
prémisses d'une guerre civile.
C'est-à-dire que dès qu'on considère que
le dialogue est rompu, que l'autre n'est
pas un adversaire mais un ennemi,
on rentre dans un processus graduel de
déshumanisation. L'autre est simplement
l'ennemi qui va devenir qui va falloir
un jour abattre. Et donc c'est ça qui
est qui est terrifiant. Et et on le voit
bien ce processus euh se met quand il se
met en place, c'est un processus qui est
Oui. qui a sa propre logique et et par
glissement successif. On glisse, on
glisse et puis un jour euh
voilà, ça
on passe à l'acte.
On passe à l'acte. on passe à l'acte et
puis
et puis il y a tellement de rencœur
accumulé et puis on a le feu d'artifice
et non ce qui
moi ce qui m'a le plus
qui a été le déclencheur du bouquin
finalement c'était de réaliser que vous
savez pendant très longtemps j'étais
journaliste et j'étais dans l'éthique de
conviction.
C'est quoi la charte de Munique ?
La quoi ? La charte de Munique.
La charte de Munique. Je sais pas.
Les droits et devoirs du journaliste.
Ça je faut me coller là. Je sais pas.
Il y a beaucoup de journalistes qui
connaissent pas ça. Ben
je connais pas. Je
je vous laisse terminer.
Et donc j'ai
quand je couvrais les conflits, je me
disais je veux être dans l'éthique de
conviction. Je veux dire je veux être au
plus près de ce que je vois pour faire
le moins d'erreurs possible. Euh
personne n'est parfait et évidemment moi
non plus. et et donc essayons d'être
d'être le plus juste possible sachant
qu'il y aura la marge d'erreur
évidemment
mais il y avait un côté assez
confortable et après lorsque à travers
notamment l'histoire du camp dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure tout à coup quand
vous vous sentez que vousz rentrer dans
une sorte vous êtes plus dans l'éthique
de conviction vous devenez vous rentrez
dans l'éthique de responsabilité
les choses sont plus si vous rentrez
dans le gris et c'est ça qui est super
difficile, c'est que finalement vous
êtes sur cette ligne de crête et que
vous devez pas verser et que c'est si
facile de verser d'un côté ou de
l'autre. Et donc pour moi, c'était ça
qui a été donc j'ai voulu prendre des
exemples super concrets que ça soit la
Syrie, que ça soit les Balcons, que ça
soit d'autres situations encore où je me
disais voilà une situation super
compliquée, comment on peut la être le
plus juste possible ?
et choisir le moindre mot finalement le
moindre mal parce que finalement à la
fin c'est ça quoi.
Question internet qui est très qui
provoque mais ça va nous nous faire
revenir peut-être à votre bouquin.
Revenons au diable. Selon lui quelles
sont la les différences entre
terroristes et résistants ? C'est une
question c'est un point de vue c'est
tout.
Je crois que c'est aussi simple que ça.
C'est un point de vue, je veux dire par
si on parle de la deuxième guerre
mondiale, les terroristes de l'un était
les résistants de l'autre.
Donc oui, non,
c'est ceux qui gagnent la guerre qui
déterminent le
Ça ça ça peut aider évidemment [rires]
si vous écrivez l'histoire, c'est vous
qui déterminez. C'est sûr.
C'était une question de Hassan. Autre,
vous avez terminé la réponse ?
Oui.
Autre question internet. Quel une
question de Camen Quelles sont les
sources les plus fréquentes de conflit ?
Doit-on s'attendre à une intensific On a
déjà répondu à ça. Une intensification
des conflits suite à la réfaction des
ressources vitales aux nourritures ?
Oui, définitivement.
On y a déjà répondu. L'enfer est en Je
les prends à la suite. L'Étant est en
L'enfer est empavé de bonnes intentions.
Peut Pe peux-tu demander à monsieur Azan
son opinion sur la responsabilité de
l'action humanitaire dans la
perturbation de certains conflits et
aussi les programmes militaraux
humanitaires ? Wouh
! C'est vaste question.
Il y a eu beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont réfléchi, notamment Renier
Broman et d'autres sur
l'instrumentalisation de l'aide
humanitaire. Et c'est sûr que euh je
vais vous donner un seul exemple, le
premier qui me vient en tête, mais j'en
ai d'autres, c'était à Sarevo. Euh il y
avait un pont aérien et je pense que la
popul je crois que le gouvernement de de
Sarayevo euh gonflait un peu la les
chiffres de la population pour pouvoir
donner aussi à ses soldats de l'aide
humanitaire. Mais en même temps, les
Serbes euh apparemment ces coucheners
qui qui avaient fait cet accord avaient
accepter que 20 % ou 23 % paraît-il de
l'aide humanitaire soit détournée pour
les Bosnuerbes. Donc évidemment dans une
dans un conflit il y a toujours une
instrumentalisation
de tout ce qui peut servir à alimenter
la guerre. Il se fait que l'aide
humanitaire aussi participe mais elle
participe surtout à soulager les
victimes. Donc inutile de revenir sur
l'Éthiopie ou sur d'autres situations où
l'aide humanitaire a été utilisée comme
appâ pour déplacer des populations. Ça a
été aussi le cas au Cambodge à un
certain moment.
On a lorsque le gouvernement
lorsque les C rouges sont tombés par du
fait de l'intervention
du gouvernement vietnamien qui était
soutenu par les soviétiques, les
occidentaux ont mis de la nourriture sur
la frontière taille cambodgien. Les gens
étaient affamés. Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ? Ils se sont précipités sur la
frontière taille combodienne et là on
les a bloqué. Ils pouvaient plus
retourner chez eux et ils sont devenus
la base de légitimité et bientôt des
soldats de la gueria pour combattre le
gouvernement mis en place par les
Vietnamiens. Donc oui, l'aide
humanitaire comme toute ressource peut
aussi favoriser
les les béérants.
Question internet, il pense quoi de
Thomas Sankara ?
Écoutez, ça c'est je je sais qu'il avait
euh qu'il avait euh euh
suscité une un espoir immense, un
immense un espoir immense par euh par sa
simplicité, par son humilité, par sa
capacité à à à dire les choses. Euh ben
il s'est fait butter.
Il s'est fait butter. Je pense que celui
qui l'a buté aujourd'hui
apparemment est de retour dans son pays.
Je ne sais pas si un jour il sera jugé.
Donc oui, tout ça laisse un goût bien
amer.
Question internet de Laurent : que
penses-t-il de l'action de Bernard Henry
Lévi à travers les conflits ?
Euh écoutez euh
il faudrait je écoutez, je la suis pas
euh je suis je suis pas BHL en fait mais
euh euh des
trucs plus intéressants peut-être non
hein
vous avez des trucs plus importants et
intéressant
il y a des choses plus intéressants. Je
pense que ce qu'il a fait en Libye était
pas le truc le plus malin pour faire
court.
Un autre point qu'on vous voulez qu'on
aborde ensemble, un point hyper
important pour notre communauté à
comprendre. Quelle est pour vous une des
clés de lecture nécessaire ?
Clé de lecture, écoutez, j'ai pas cette
pré prétention. Je dirais que il faut
voir les médiations et les processus de
paix comme des choses, comment on dit en
anglais ? Incremental, des choses qui se
font petit à petit. Il faut pas voir du
tout rien et chose et chaque chaque pas
qui va dans la bonne direction ce n'est
pas utile parce que vous construisez
vous construisez avec l'autre vous vous
vous réapprenez en fait et vous aider
chaque à chaque partie aussi à quelque
part débloquer une sorte d'espace mental
de réfléchir sur véritablement quelles
sont ces lignes rouges parce que souvent
ce qui m'a frappé le plus et pour moi
c'est un des grands moments dans dans un
processus plus de facilitation quand
vous êtes surtout avec une seule partie.
Euh la personne vous dit "Je veux ça".
Dites "d'accord, mais pourquoi tu le
veux véritablement ?" et vous l'obligez
à à élaborer à élaborer à élaborer et
à verbaliser
à verbaliser à élaborer davantage. Et là
vous comprenez que peut-être il y a des
marches de manœuvre ici ou là que
peut-être que quand il dit ça ben il
peut-être c'était un peu autre chose
qu'il voulait vraiment dire et donc tout
ce processus disons de clarification des
lignes rouges des véritables lignes
rouges des véritables intérêts. En soi,
c'est un processus absolument, je trouve
intellectuellement fascinant mais aussi
porteur de transformation. Et donc,
j'essaie de toujours
réfléchir en terme de transformation.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut transformer pour
pour essayer de bouger d'un d'un
millimètre finalement les lignes ?
Comment on peut je vais je vais me poser
en avocat du diable.
Comment on fait alors qu'il y a des non
dit, il y a des agendas cachés, il y a
des il y a des stratégies derrière à à
moyen et long terme, des stratégies
énergétiques, des stratégies comment on
fait alors que en fait huit étages plus
haut en fait ils sont sur un cap au
bulldozer et vous en fait vous êtes
l'infirmière qui essaie de sauver les
petites champs. Ouais, mais la question
que vous posez, la le fond de la
question que vous posez, c'est une
question super importante. C'est qui
fait l'histoire ? C'est votre question.
Et il y a des gens qui croient qu'ils
font l'histoire parce qu'ils sont 8e
étage.
J'en suis pas persuadé.
Ça c'est une belle belle réponse ça.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Des
bouquins qui ont été importants pour
vous ou des bouquins importants à lire
pour notre communauté ? Écoutez des
bouquins importants pour pour moi. Je
pense à Hanna,
il y en a un qui s'appelle il y en a
plein et procès àma un procès à
Jérusalem
que j'ai trouvé intérêt que je que
j'aime beaucoup, je trouve qui est très
vivifiant, très stimulant.
euh
de Paul Ricker, pas facile à lire mais
euh mais il a écrit des trucs
incroyables sur Je suis pas bon pour les
titres. Euh
la mémoire, l'histoire et l'oublie. La
mémoire, l'histoire et l'oublie. Euh
et puis puis j'adore Camu quoi.
Alors les chroniques c'est ça ? Ouais,
mais aussi euh
chronique d'Algérie où il a écrit son
journal, il a écrit des très très belles
choses.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable ?
Ouais. Aimer et désirer, c'est tout. Ça
suffit.
Pierre Azon, merci.
Merci à vous surtout.
[musique]